场子会有什么样子的
心里有什么样的感受
首先再次谢谢来到现场
你们刚才我只有看到摄影大哥
我现在看到你们觉得很开心
今天你们还是有来到现场访问我
呵呵呵呃
唱完两场其实还是觉得很兴奋诶
我本来想说
因为那个我们机关真的很多
所以我们彩排的呃
真的花了很久的时间彩排这样
然后呃哦我就会想说哦
再加上这个连两场
我可能是一连唱了四场这样
然后是不是哦可能哦体能状态啊什么的
会觉得好像会比较疲惫一点
但是不晓得是现在是怎么太开心了
就觉得嗯如果再唱一场的话
好像也可以哦
哦但我开玩笑的
明天礼拜班大家上班了
对唱完有没有最想做什么
喝两杯
哎我的舞者们他们也超级期待
因为其实我们呃对于这个排练的话
因为舞蹈部分其实真的是也变了很多
然后所以像舞者们也都蛮辛苦的
然后我就答应他们说
我说现在给我夹紧屁股好好练
然后呃庆功宴的时候
我们在大家好好放松
好好喝
你是有特别戒了一段时间吗
开薪水了
借不用借啊
说停就停啊
停多久多久
有一个礼拜以上吧
什么哈哈哈哈游啦
有有吧
有有一个礼拜以上
这样超超过超过
因为我们还是要保护我的喉咙
超过一个月嗯
一个月
所以差不多等一下要把一个月的份合回来吗
哦我可怕
所以我的肝一下早上没有办法承受这么多
但就是反正要把呃
这段时间大家就是绷紧神经的那个心
好好在
今天晚上可能跟工作伙伴们一起放松一下
好好谢谢他们
嗯听到大半个演艺圈都在世纪婚礼那边
自己心情有心一惊一下吗
想说啊心友会不会都不在这样子也不会啊
因为我觉得那是喜事啊
对啊
那嗯呃就是如果我不开演唱会
我可能也很想去啦
哈哈哈哈对呀
就很祝福他们
对这个是很很很很开心
很多喜事
然后而且其实有很多好朋友们
其实昨天都来了
昨天来了
然后今天去也也辛苦这些朋友们的了
两天要赶两团
这样清风
我送了一双玻璃鞋
好像是什么爱情的玻璃鞋在哪呼应那个歌词嘛
对不对
OK有一些什么意有所指吗
哪里有啊
这样子也可以问玻璃鞋啊
这样也可以问歌词
你的歌词啊
那你不如说灰姑娘好了
嗯好好
她心有所属了吗
嗯怎么办
哈哈哈哈怎么办
这个好
下一题哈哈哈哈哈
所以清清风是明白你的状况是不是对
下一题谢谢
所以今天是不是因为这一题哈
怎么会唱的是这样
怎么样说这件世纪婚礼特约赵清风来尬场
是不是啊对呀哈哈哈哈哈哈对不是
因为其实我刚开始也不知道世纪婚礼
因为小巨蛋这个时间
因为小巨蛋也不是时间也不是很好定
很早就确定了
然后才知道说哎呀这个第二天症状世纪婚礼
可是那时候在邀请青峰的时候
我也还搞不清楚
就是就是今今天大家各自的排成这样子
然后我只是觉得说呃好朋友青峰
我从来就我们俩从来没有在台上合体过这样
然后呃所以这次就嗯找了第一天找的告五人
第一天找清风
其实就是很自然的一个把我喜欢的好朋友
我喜欢的歌手邀请来我的演唱会
这样这是我练到累出病了
我觉得好像肾上腺素还可以
就是反正就是抽筋啊这一类的
然后还好前阵子感冒了
所以就后来好了之后
就你知道感冒可能就有抗体
所以这段时间都还可以
哪里有木头
赶快先帮我敲一下
他体重有创新低啊
嗯嗯其实我这几天就没凉了
我这几天就索性不良体重了
对那一般到这个时候都不会太重嘛
对点应该是煎的吧
苦很煎煎
那你开放前饮食有特别节制吗
就可能都不吃
这样他不行
我一定要吃
我其实唱歌一定要吃肉跟饭对
所以造财饮食没有特别没有
我觉得这个真的是
要谢谢我妈妈跟我自己的努力
就是妈妈生的好跟跟跟运动没有特别忌口
可能不吃辣就可以
嗯其实我没有忌口
就不要吃到太辣
但我还是会吃辣
我觉得就是我还是正常啦
听懂他锁吻你有很害羞吗
不会啊
他如果他如果真的其实我们刚很靠近他
如果真的OK新上来后
我嗯孙子我是觉得不太可能吧
我就想我就在靠近他的时候
想说他有没有要躲
如果没有要躲的话
我也是蛮惊讶的
那也那也就这样啊
呵呵就顺其自然的发生
我们以为你们刚会真亲哈
想看吗
想看让我们欢迎清风
你都夺了很多第一次吗
这边现做对我们第一次的合作
跟呃我们呃他第一次写给我的歌
这样马上就是访问完之后
应该就会有第二次就会出现了
第一次这样子合体唱歌啦
是之前是因为什么原因
有就是比较忙
约不到他这样子嗯
就是他可能比较忙
所以他没办法当家
这嗯也没有
我觉得这次清风真的很有义气
我们呃其实就是第一次想说哦
好像要一直在台上合作
他也就一口答应
而且他还延迟
好像还延迟了一些他的原本的安排的行程
然后一口答应来嗯
那些在台上呃
有刚有一位上台的歌迷
好像比你还了解自己的歌
是不是那时候有点哇哦没有
后来他那个那个不晓是kk box还是SPA
把一放之后我就会了
我也不知道是我的问题还是他的问题好了
应该是我的问题
但我的歌迷应该好像也都蛮习惯我这样子
然后好像蛮喜欢看我这样子的
好OK那个高雄场会有可能哦
有在努力哦
要问张杰呃
要问林老板
高雄场还可以开到两场啊
哦要先有再说啦
对啊先有林老板来换换
你答一下这题哦
好OK谢谢谢谢